so my name is heather miller i'm a phd
student
at epfl in switzerland i work with
martin odersky on the scholar
programming language
if you know scala like you might i might
have i mean i do documentation for scala
i whoops i worked on a bunch of
libraries that people might know
like the futures library the futures and
promises library
did some work on data flow and and for
like the last several months i've been
working on
better language support for well not
pure embedded in the compiler language
support but
trying to help out distributed
programming uh
closer to the language in scala and so
today i'm going to talk about something
that sounds kind of funny it's called
the pickles and spores this is two
different projects
they each have hilarious names but
they each kind of are complementary in
their
in how they try to sort of assist making
different machines communicate
so this is also all joint work with
uh philip pollarat type safe eugene he
ran away somewhere
he just gave this macros talk and of
course martin uh
so um as i've already alluded to this
talk is about trying to
make distributed programming scala a
little bit easier
there's a lot of drama when it comes to
trying to get two machines to
reliably talk and i'm not just talking
about like this
massively parallel like you know big
data
type server farm stuff it's also just
pushing data to devices and other things
like this
so like i said machines communicating
and how can we simplify
sort of this as close to the level of
language as possible can we use type
systems for example to help out a little
bit
uh so like i said i have these two
projects one called spores
and one called pickling and about 75 of
the talk today is going to be about the
spores stuff
so if you saw i have some slides online
and some uh
some a video and everything about about
uh the talk that has a similar name that
i gave at scala days earlier this year
and it was mostly about the pickling
part of the project this is mostly about
the spores part of the stuff
uh and the other yeah quarters gonna be
pickling and the cool stuff about this
is that it's not only
research stuff that i put my head down
and do in a lab and never talk to
anybody
about it's actually stuff that is useful
and is being used by people
and some of it is a little bit more
researchy and i don't know how useful it
might be
but you'll see that side of it today so
for example for the pickling stuff
it's going to be at upsla this year
we're going to present like
all the nitty gritty details about how
we do the pickling which is
some really crazy macro magic generating
stuff at
compile time uh and that's the research
component of it but it's actually used
by a handful of companies already and
we're supposed to have a stable release
for the last several days
the strange loop talk sort of uh
eclipsed my my ability to make this
deadline but
we don't even have a stable release it's
supposed to be like today or yesterday
or tomorrow that the first table or
lease is supposed to actually be made
and people are like i said are already
using it
um and so spores the other project um
again it's also academic we have a a
more formal component of it and
also a study of sort of the practical
benefits of what these four things
provide
to uh to users of scala as well as
sort of the practical component which
it's actually currently proposed to be
included in the language in 211
um well the language as in the
distribution
not the compiler um and we've already
we've already posted this
scholar improvement proposal and have
gotten lots of feedback and have
reformulated the whole design of the
thing based on people's feedback
and uh we're soon going to release a
prototype of that which will be
in scala 211 hopefully so
let's start talking about this forest
stuff um
so i'm sorry if the text is a little bit
dark i didn't realize it would be so
hard to see but
first let's just imagine that we're
thinking about the single machine
model right now forget about this whole
distribution thing
we really like closures closures are
really nice if you
if you have a functional programming
language you need function literals
closures all these things you need to be
passing them around
um and functional programming is largely
about transforming data
in some way transforming immutable data
in some way
and they're often just represented as
functions right closures
so things like monads that are backed by
so monets backed by data like lists or
options or futures or these kinds of
things these are typically
you know acted on by functions that are
passed to higher order functions right
or closures past higher order functions
so you can kind of think about it like
you're
passing functions or sorry closures
around to the data
if you think about it like that right
and i mean you know functions are so
nice that you know even slow-moving
languages like java eventually
want to pick them up so they're great
right okay
distributed land they're still cool but
yeah you can't really
move them around to different machines
easily in most programming languages
some some some functional languages are
better than others scala is not so good
at it
in any sort of you know language on the
jvm has has trouble
moving closures from one machine to
another
and so oops the question why is this the
case
there's a lot of reasons um often most
often
uh things the closures are i'm sorry
closures are not serializable because
they capture stuff that is also
transitively not serializable
so if you accidentally capture
you know your a reference to your
enclosing object
and your closing object is not
serializable then okay everything it
crashes at runtime
great you can accidentally capture stuff
that's not serializable
totally unknowingly or you can just
unknowingly capture everything
like all of wikipedia accidentally
because it's a graph that's heavily
highly connected and just actually
serialize that and send it over the wire
whoops
uh so then there's a bunch of you know
like i said the the bottom line is
usually
you capture stuff that you don't want to
capture you send it over the wire
usually the problem is runtime errors
instead of compile time ones
and uh sort of the drama that usually
presents itself is that you know note
like from these stack traces you never
know whose fault it was
uh it often looks like it's the
framework's fault when maybe the user
captured something wrong
so those are some problems and
consequences that follow from those
problems are that typically framework
builders don't really want to ever put
them in their public apis
because they usually bring all kinds of
drama you don't want
you know users accidentally capturing
bad stuff and then everything breaking
and it being your fault right
also it's not a good idea to put them in
your private apis or not your private
apis but to use them privately either
because uh some small refactoring of
your code base
could result in some closure
accidentally capturing more than it did
on the previous commit or something in
some really
obscure runtime error and you have no
idea what that's all about
so i mean it's just generally avoided uh
so when picking battles from presenters
i think have a tendency to avoid issues
with closures like you know very
rightfully so because of this capturing
problem
this problem of this evil environment
doing wrong things all the time
and the funniest part about all of this
is that i'm sure everybody's heard this
before that like functional programming
is the way to go if you want to do
parallel concurrent distributed stuff
i mean concurrent too right you have all
this mutable stuff
you pass the functions around to sort of
you know
do things in parallel you can balance
you can do all kinds of like load
balancing based
on like you know shards of immutable
data and functions and all kinds of
stuff like this right
um and like i said passing functions
around is a way to do functional
programming in general right
but uh as i've alluded to already
managing closures in these concurrent or
distributed environments
or writing apis uh to be used by clients
in situations like these is
usually pretty dramatic and precarious
and dangerous right
so wouldn't it be really nice if we
could
not have to worry so much about the
stuff that a closure captures
and be able to reliably build new types
of frameworks for distributed
programming
based on passing functions around that
would be cool because there's not a lot
of frameworks that really do that at
least in scholar
so that's where the spore idea comes
from
and today i'm going to talk about two
types so i previously alluded to the
fact that
some of these projects are a little bit
more researchy in nature some of them
are actually proposed for inclusion in
the language
uh so the first one to talk about are
the main line spores i'll call them and
they're the ones that are proposed for
inclusion at 211
and then i'm going to spend a few slides
talking about this more researchy
topic i call them spores with type
constraints so it's basically
using the type system to try and you
know
also give your users a contract about
what you don't want them to capture
right and that's some research i'm going
to read a paper about that soon
but first let's talk about these
mainline spores
so again they you can think about spores
like these
small units of potentially potentially
possibly mobile functional behavior they
don't actually have to be necessarily
like
i've already said a few times that
they're kind of useful in concurrent
environments as well and i'll show you
example
but they are effectively a closure-like
abstraction for use in distributed and
concurrent environments
and the goal of this effort of spores in
general
are to provide well-behaved closures in
which the environment is very well
controlled and it avoids all kinds of
bad sort of hazards that present
themselves in these types of
environments
so um well one thing of course is memory
leaks if you have an idea of what you're
what's in your environment you can
probably avoid leaking memory often
but the the bigger concerns are race
conditions
uh that that can present themselves due
to accidentally
uh capturing mutable references in a
concurrent environment
and then all this runtime serialization
drama due to the capturing problem that
i've already
talked a little bit about i hope you can
see this
um so this i'm just gonna i'm gonna give
a few
motivating examples right now
does anybody know spark it's a it's a
cool
cluster computing framework or whatever
i don't know how to describe it it's an
in-memory
distributed collections framework
basically so
you can imagine kind of like hadoop but
it's all in memory it's much faster and
you have a lot more operations available
to you so
you can just use uh they co they're
called rdds so this thing here
this is the it's like a distributed
array and you can
you know call a lot of a lot of uh of
functions that you find in the scala
collections library like
map flat map filter all these things
that are you're regularly used to using
uh and it's really nice because it's it
because it's in memory it's super fast
uh so you can basically do interactive
queries and get and get results back
right away
right and the way that it works is that
you have a bunch of these this data
partitioned all over a bunch of
different nodes and you're effectively
uh taking oops you're you're passing
this this rdd thing
uh well you're calling this map function
on on your rdd which takes a a function
right
and uh you know the same problem that
i've
been going on about for a while now you
can catch all kinds of bad stuff in this
so in this example it looks pretty
innocuous doesn't look like it's that
bad you know
i'm just going to capture this this you
know number here put it
here add it with whatever i pass to uh
my map function
do whatever is in reduce whatever it's
not a big deal but the problem is
that uh actually this function is not
serializable because
what has to happen is oops what has to
happen
is uh there's the secret this
reference the secret uh reference to the
enclosing uh
instance right so this this my cool rdd
app
uh basically this is uh this this dot
whatever param right and uh because this
guy this guy isn't serializable none of
this can be serialized
uh that's one dramatic problem then you
know results in runtime
errors uh another case so this is not
distributed this is a concurrency
example so does anybody know akka actors
this whole thing cool so if you know
anything about actors what you typically
have to do
is you have to implement this receive
method which is the the method the
message
uh handler for the for you know so you
basically match on all different types
of messages
and then you you you know you implement
some logic for handling that message
uh and what's often done if you have if
you're if your actor has to
to process a long-running task uh you
you know you want to try and maybe use
futures or something because actors are
you don't want to like keep many of them
busy processing something long running
you want to get to the next message in
your mailbox right
so people often wrap stuff in these
futures right which so the thing returns
immediately
and then it gets basically picked up by
another thread and then executed by that
other thread
the problem is that there's all kinds of
stuff that can be captured that's
unstable
in this example this thing called sender
sender means basically every message has
a sender and it represents the the the
actor that sent the message to you
right and if you if you think about it
if you know so the mailbox is processing
these things and only knows one sender
at a time
uh and so if you you know make this
asynchronous and throw it in the future
and have it executed later
uh basically whatever message the
actor's mailbox
is that's like you know that that the
actor's mailbox is handling
uh this is this this is the the
the sender that uh of so this is this is
basically what the sender points to
so it could be some other messages
sender right and the thing is that that
it's not a stable value it's actually a
method call
so basically you're asking the mailbox
what the current sender is
and this is a common problem of akka
users
so the problem again is that basically
you tried to capture something that
doesn't have a stable value and it
changes
it changes its meaning over time and you
don't know when this this closure which
the future is basically a closure you
don't know when this is going to be
evaluated
and then there's just like infinity
logical errors as a result of this kind
of stuff
and this is just another serialization
error where again you capture
the enclosing the enclosing instance so
it's it's actually very similar to the
first example that i showed you you've
got some helper class
everything lives in this main class and
you have a function here
that calls the local helper but actually
it's
this dot whatever this.helper2string
that's called and again that's the same
problem where the whole thing isn't
serialized when you get a runtime error
okay you got it i hope you got the point
this happens all the time there's all
this drama all the time with
concurrent and distributed or rather
situations you need to serialize things
right so
okay we should do something about it
right so there are these four things
what do they look like
so a sport looks a little bit like a
normal closure
so here's your closure there's also so
it's got this
this four marker thing this four block
here
and there's this funny val guy here so
there's a there's two parts of a spore
you have the sequence of these local
value declarations so this this here you
can have a list of these so you can have
many values
and this represents the environment that
your closure has is going to capture
uh and basically the the the
you also have this closure as well and
the rules
oops actually the rules are on another
slide i'll talk about them in a second
actually i think i lost them okay
uh so basically the the deal is this
that your closure
can only refer to stuff in your in your
local environment you've
explicitly captured yourself so you know
what you have in your environment
and the benefit of that is that
you capture stuff explicitly and when
you do this
uh the initializer the captured
variables are executed upon the creation
of the spore so they're stable
they don't change like this funny center
thing does so basically in the previous
example where i showed you the actor
thing
if this you know val s equals you know
you know you you
create your sender here or whatever you
call center there then you have an actor
ref that's stable and doesn't change
and then the whole problem goes away um
right so that's just what i said here so
the benefit is that everything your
entire environment becomes stable
and another thing about this is that
spores aren't some funny
like compiler magic they don't the
compiler doesn't go
and do some crazy transformation to your
sport
what it does is i mean you can think
about it very simply like you can just
remove the spore marker
in this example here just remove this
guy leave it in your block and it gets
evaluated exactly the same it gets
executed exactly the same
right so evaluation is is effectively
the same all we do
is we make sure that you don't capture
dangerous
environments right but otherwise
everything gets evaluated in the same
way
and i should also note that sports
enclosures are related you can actually
if you have an api that takes a spore
you can
pass a function literal to it so long as
the function literal
um abides by the the score rules
so um here's an example actually
of of something taking us for so it's
the same kind of
syntax as a function you know you have
your your
your input and your output and basically
you can pass
a function literal to it here and uh
the it's basically it's an implicit
conversion that gets applied and then
you know all the checking gets applied
and you know assuming that your your
spore
or your function abides by these rules
then you're good
okay another thing that we can do with
spores is four comprehensions is another
way to use them
um if you know anything about how
scala does four comprehensions it
actually just
de-sugars to calls to high order
functions like
map flat map with filter these things
and if you think about it you have to
pass functions to these these guys
so naturally when you use a four
comprehension then you have this problem
of spores that you don't actually
explicitly define yourself
but you can still you can still use four
comprehensions with things that take
spores
so in this whoops so in this example if
we have a something
some type of distributed collection you
have your your combinators here
uh you can still define a so basically
all of this gets executed and set on
with with spores and not normal closures
and there's this funny little capture
syntax which basically
uh is like an inline version of this way
of listing oops
this way of listing your your value
declarations so it's like a way of
inlining it right
um okay and so those are the the
the main ways to use spores you define
them as as four values
you uh you use them in four
comprehensions
oops or you pass them as as
as parameters to things
so right what does that get you
like i said captured expressions are
evaluated upon
creation of the spore so everything is
stable you have an immutable environment
that's
perfectly safe and it's also checked and
so there's no accidental capturing that
you can have
so you can think about it like this if
this is a spore
and this is a closure you can have uh
some something that you're trying to
capture here some primitives some random
objects
and they all get like resolved and are
dealt with at the time the thing is
created right
uh whereas in a normal closure um
all of this basically ends up uh
being seen by the so the compiler sees
these things as calls to outer
outer enclosing objects and things like
this
which is problematic if you want to
create this thing and then send it to
another machine and you have all of
these references to
to other objects that you don't even
know about because it's not explicitly
in your code
and only when you actually evaluate that
function do all of those references to
other things kind of
eventually go away and as you can see as
you can imagine like if you
you know want to create something then
send it to another machine and then
evaluate it naturally you're going to
have all kinds of problems if it's
capturing all kinds of other stuff
so what ends up happening is you end up
capturing
all kinds of crazy objects that you
don't even know about but in the case of
spores it's all the same
so from the time that you create the
thing it's the same at
the time the environment is the same
when you execute it so it's like it
actually the funny thing is that
it it actually pulls in funny stuff in
your object graph even if it's not
even if it's not even if the things are
serializable in your object graph it
pulls in a crazy object that you don't
even know about
so this is kind of like you know in my
mind what it looks like
this looks a lot safer pass those around
okay the sort of motivation for
these funny spore things that don't do a
lot but enforce a certain style is that
it
kind of makes it possible to
you know it enables much cool new
patterns right so a few just
ideas of things that you can do and
things that we've tried but you know
they could be expanded into bigger into
bigger things right
so one pattern uh i call it stage and
ship
basically the idea is that if you have a
function you can build up a comp or i'm
sorry
a spore you can build up a computation
graph with these spores
uh with the behavior represented as
spores and once uh
once you've composed all these things
into some sort of uh graph you can send
it over to another machine
and then you know have that machine
invoke or sorry uh
apply your spores uh yeah so you can
think about like pipeline stages that
are plugged together and one machine is
set to another
another is some type of uh like function
passing
uh style concurrency so imagine the same
kind of thing
but instead of passing it to one machine
you can pass it to a bunch of machines
right so you can compose stuff as you go
like you compose on one machine spend it
to another machine compose it again send
it around
uh another thing that you can do with
this is you can actually hot swap
behavior between machines
with actors so in akka you have this
become method
and basically it takes a partial
function and
you know let's just say that we could
take a spore or something
then you could basically you know
actually hot swap behavior between
machines
yeah change the way that the thing
handles messages for example
so these are patterns that aren't you
know
often used for i think a lot of dramatic
reasons and
i think it could enable a bunch of
cooler
more reliable frameworks so what
actually spark is is really awesome
and it's really taking off in all
and at least in the startup scene and
especially when it comes to
you know querying data quickly right
they but they have this problem very
regularly on their mailing list where
they like i said they expose these
functions to users and there's just
infinity drama
so i mean you could have more reliable a
more reliable spark or other other
abstractions that are like spark
same kind of thing for these pipelines
you can build up these pipelines and
and distribute them a lot easier and
then
you know the same stuff that i was
talking about a moment ago this function
passing stuff where you can compose
functions on different machines and pass
them around
all right that's nice
but what if you want to capture
something that you shouldn't capture
like a socket
so if you capture a socket send it to
another machine and try to send
something to that socket what does that
even mean
it doesn't make sense right but
right now spores so this is this is
where the spores the type constraints
come in this is ken
i know i should have made more of these
yeah i
i'm gonna make sure there's more kitty
slides and more of my presentations in
the future
thank you for your enthusiasm
but um so yeah this is something that's
a little bit more researchy it's
closer to the realm of of dealing with
types uh
and uh so yeah if you have some socket
type
it would be nice if in the current
framework it currently you can't do this
in the framework that i just
presented to you there's no way of
saying i don't want i don't want a
socket
don't capture socket that's bad but it
would be really nice if you could
actually add these constraints in some
way for example it would be nice if aka
could say hey don't capture an actor
that doesn't make any sense to try and
send an actor to another machine you
can't really do that
at least easily you want to capture an
actor ref do that you know so it'd be
nice
if akka could for example provide you
know don't capture actors
in their in their api and then your code
gets rejected if you accidentally try to
do that
right so that's where the spores with
type constraints idea comes in
basically the idea is that at compile
time you want to try and keep track of
all the types that you captured
so the stuff that's in your environment
and you also want to keep track of the
types that you wish not to capture
again i'm really sorry if it's hard to
see
so you remember the spores and text i
showed you earlier you've got something
called a spore you got this value
definition list and then you got your
function or your closure here right
and then you assume that this guy is
only referencing these things
all right so this assuming that uh
so the only addition is this this
exclude method that passes this
actor type parameter right basically all
this says is yeah okay
do some stuff but don't make sure
there's no actor in here make sure that
no matter what i capture there's no way
i accidentally capture an actor
so all this would be implemented or is
implemented uh with sport uh with macros
so this these four macros can actually
synthesize the precise types
automatically uh for the new spores that
you'd wish to create that have these
constraints
so this is what this the type of the
thing would look like
uh of this thing here so
you've got these two type members uh
excluded in facts
and excluded of course are the things
you don't want to capture for example an
actor
and facts are the things you have
captured so in this case we've
captured an int and an actor ref right
and so here i have a full description
in types of what the spore is doing
um and just like normal functions
spores have two operators
uh two composition operators and then
and compose
and they just reverse the way that you
apply these functions to each other
and in the case of spores and with type
constraints these things would be macros
as well
and what they basically do so you might
ask if i'm try if i compose two spores
and they each have different type
conspiracy constraints what happens then
um and effectively so like i said you
have this facts and this excluded
type member so you take the two
component parts
these two component spores each of their
individual facts components
you just take the union of these and
then the excluded member
what you do first is you take the
conjunction of the excluded types and
you need to check
to make sure that
you don't have one of these excluded
types inside of your facts
you reject things if you do it's kind of
simple
this is not what you would have to write
this is just
a way that this is just what it looks
like with the types but here's an
example
so say you have two spores s1 and s2
they each have this excluded in this fax
member
so you in this s1 you don't want to
capture an actor and this s2 you don't
want to capture an rdd
but you captured an int and an actor
okay that's fine you didn't capture an
actor that's good
s2 you capture you don't want to are you
captured an actor but you don't want to
capture an rdd that's also fine you can
do that
but then if you want to compose them you
want to make sure that this doesn't
compile
you can't see that but it says don't
this doesn't compile
that's because right here i this guy
says it captured an actor and the
composition of these two
this guy says it doesn't want to it does
it you can't capture an actor
you know and yeah this shouldn't
logically it shouldn't make sense um
and this is an example that should
compile actually there's an empty
type number missing here it should be
type facts with you know whatever
there's an empty type anyway so
basically you can think about
s1 being same as before and s2 is having
no constraints at all
and then when you compose them yes
everything should be fine you should get
a
a new type now so the the the resulting
type of the composition
as you can see the first spor the first
function is into string
the next one is string to string so then
this this one is going to be
the composition of them is going to be
inter-string and then you have the union
oops well because because this type
checks you have the union basically of
the
of the or the conjunction of the two uh
the actor and the rdd excluded types and
then of course you have the union of all
of the
the the capture types okay cool
so that's also uh so so what do these
type constraints get us
so it gives you uh stronger constraints
that are beyond just the basic spore
checking the basic shape checking and
the thing that enforces you to
to write nicer environments it's a
little bit more than that it gives it
gives framework authors a little bit
more confidence
about uh exposing functions to users and
preventing stuff
in their framework from being captured
by their users
that's the point so also something i
i think i haven't i haven't mentioned is
that these constraints
as you can probably imagine from this
previous example is that they accumulate
monotonically
and so you can't ever lose a constraint
so you can keep composing these things
for a long time and then your
your basically your your contract gets
stricter and stricter
ideally this should be a lot less
brittle
when it comes to accidental the cap the
the problem of accidental capture
and that's all i really have to say
about spores for now
if you ever want to get into the details
there's going to be a paper soon about
spores
so you can knock yourself out or dig
through the implementation
now oopsle is the pickling stuff i'm
going to show you in a second
uh this hasn't been submitted yet so
we'll see
it'll be a draft on the internet you'll
be able to find it if you look up this
board stuff
so
oh yeah uh i have on all the slides here
oops there's this this url i'm going to
post these and they're also probably
going to be in this repository this
strangely repository but
the the language improvement proposal
which has more details than this
is is posted on scholarly.org
so you can see and then you can also
argue that some decisions are bad if you
want
knock yourself out there's also a
mailing list for that you know he can
throw down and fight the mailing list
all right so onto something completely
different
sort of different it's actually similar
these things
so this is the pickling part of the
project or the pickling project
pickling half of my talk or the pickling
quarter of my talk i should say
i should also note that this whole thing
about spores is all about being able to
effectively serialize them but i haven't
yet unified these two things
they will be one day unified so pickling
and sports should play together but
right now they're independent
so um we released
uh well we open sourced or released a
preview version of this pickling
framework the url is here
it's under the scala organization the
repository is called pickling
we did this back at like the end of the
middle of june
uh and it's a serial it's an automatic
serialization framework
uh seriousation marshaling pickling
they're all synonyms
uh but the thing that you should
probably remember is that it's extremely
different from the way java does it
which makes it more convenient usually
so uh to give you one sentence to
explain the difference
java does everything closer to the jvm
or closer to the runtime
so it figures out how to serialize
things uh
you know while your program is running
whereas the pickling framework does as
much as it can at compile
time and it inlines the serialization
stuff
in at the use site so uh basically if
you're trying to serialize something to
json
basically what gets inlined is uh calls
to your
well basically the entire json message
uh implemented a bunch of string
concatenation like
inline your code and it's really fast so
yeah why do we need another
serialization framework we have java but
it's slow
and it's closed and actually so the slow
thing yeah
it's it's good that our framework is
pretty fast uh
but i what i think is really important
is the fact that like every
serialization framework that exists for
the jvm is completely closed you can't
just say all right
spit out xml spit out json spit out
binaries put out whatever i'm going to
invent something spit that out
um you're always tied to some format and
this is nice because it's not tied to
any format you can implement your own
uh also java has all this drama with you
know having to mark things as
serializable and then
somewhere something doesn't get marked
as serializable you have to figure out
what
and there's all these exceptions at
runtime and also you can't retroactively
make something serializable if you try
to
mark something as serializable and some
brother if some guy releases
some library and it's forgets to mark
something serializable then you can't
use it as or you can't serialize it as a
client right
you can't just later make it
serializable that's annoying sometimes
too
so the benefits of scala pickling
so it's faster usually a lot faster than
java it's faster than other
frameworks like it's faster than cryo
in a lot of our benchmarks if it's not
faster it's usually on par with cryo
it's really flexible so you can
customize it in a lot of ways
uh you can and also like the whole
flexibility thing
because it's based on on type classes
and generating type classes and all of
this stuff
you can basically extend or you can you
can extend it very easily
or change the way it serializes things
very easily
um and yeah it also makes it so you can
retroactively make some random type
serializable
because oops because all these type
classes get generated at compile time
uh there's really absolutely no
boilerplates like python's pickle you
can just call pickle on something
and then like i said there's these
plugable formats so you can just
in one line change how you output your
data
so and then oh yeah the the final point
is that it's a lot more type safe you
catch a lot of stuff at a compile time
rather than runtime like in the java
world
so uh what does it look like
import the pickling package you choose
your serialization for um sorry your
your pickle format you make something
that you want to serialize
and then you just call pickle on it
that's it
it's the same front pickling take some
instance of something call it on pickle
you have to pass the type parameter like
what the type that you expect to it
and it figures out how to make it
like i said it's pretty fast so i'm just
going to show a few benchmarks
um this is a micro benchmark on
collections so
the x axis here is the size of the
collect of a collection in this case
it's a vector
and this is time on the y axis and java
is much slower as you can see so here
we're faster most of the time than cryo
and then when we get to about a million
elements we're about the same
that's cryo 2 this is cryo one and these
are naive
handwritten pickler combinators and this
is what the whole framework is based
upon
so we generate pickler combinators at
compile time it's like
you can kind of think about it like
haskell's driving a little bit but you
know specialize on pickling
this is uh what the memory usage looks
like of course more is better
we use less memory than all the other
frameworks
quite quite a lot less memory
and of course also the the size of the
serialized bytes it's about the same as
cryo and it's much much smaller than
java so
overall it uses less memory it
serializes things to a smaller
representation and it's much faster than
java especially we have another
benchmark
we call it geotrellis so geotrellis is a
it's a geographic data processing
framework i guess uh the types in this
framework so
they they send these they send these
these data types over the wire and
they're basically
arrays of primitives wrapped in case
classes
and as you can see scala pickling does
is a lot faster as the the size of these
collections get bigger
another another another benchmark is
evactor so it differs from this one
because this is like one big object
being sent over like one big collection
being sent over the wire
this is a lot of little ones this is a
lot of little uh case classes with like
one or two
primitive fields and java explodes
really fast
so we had to remove it from the
benchmark basically i mean
like it really there's only a few
thousand elements it explodes so
basically
whatever six thousand or so instances uh
that is trying to serialize and explodes
um and this is as we get up to around
what actually i think about the 40 000 i
don't know why it stops at 38 but we
went up to about 40 000 elements and
scott pickling still out performs cryo
by
enough um or it's comparable like i said
so yeah there's a bunch more benchmarks
especially in this paper
where you can deal with all kinds of
stuff like subtyping and object graphs
and
so for example if you want a serious if
you have uh
you know like this case class person you
have a case class firefighter which
extends person
and then you try to serialize
firefighter
uh if you deseri if you if you unpickle
it
and say it's a type person you're going
to get back an instance of firefighter
so i mean it deals with all of the
subtypes and everything like this
correctly
which is also uh something that
fundamentally pickler commentators don't
care about
so it's another uh sort of researchy win
that we had
um but yeah so that that's just the
default behavior that's when you call
pickle not pickle don't do anything else
and it's really fast so you can actually
customize it like i said so
you can you can uh implement your own
pickler for specific types
or you can uh implement your own custom
picker formats
uh how much time do i have actually
okay so basically i'm about done which
is good because i got like two more
slides
awesome um so this this looks like a
bunch of code
but it's it's pretty simple if you look
at it so there's this case class person
it's got three fields and uh basically
all i'm doing with this custom person
particular thing
it's only serializing two of the fields
so and i can just
say how i want the framework to
serialize anything and i mean this is
not
super boiler plate free but it's not so
bad right
so you could like i said customize how
it actually gets serialized uh you can
output to any format so this is the api
for creating your own
pickle format so um you just have to
basically say how the the message should
begin and be
like how the fields and objects within
it should be delimited um
and you have this builder thing and it's
not a huge api
and it's pretty pretty tractable to
implement your own pickle format
and here uh like i'll post these slides
online
but this is an example of basically
creating a
the pickler for a builder basically
uh for this edn this this edn format
which is
closures data transfer format i think
it's only specified i don't think it's
actually
implemented in any way yet i don't know
but yeah
here's what it looks like it's very
simple you just create a new package and
then put that stuff in it and that's all
uh and uh so the pickling project
is about to have its first stable
release
we're we've got support for a bunch of
stuff
most types uh cyclic object graphs all
kinds of things
no support for inner classes yet lots of
tests it's becoming more and more stable
it's
can serialize basically everything right
now uh we have skal 211 as a target
and we uh in the next few steps are to
integrate it with a bunch of our
frameworks and to produce a sip for
211 and that's that's everything
so um yeah
questions
yep
like you mean you want to put some type
of versioning information
so you have like different yeah if i
change the contract later if i still
realize something
yeah so it doesn't it doesn't this is
what is this
uh uh what's the term for this like
unanticipated evolution or whatever that
like a lot of these protobuf and things
like this are good at
this is this wasn't really the goal of
the framework and i haven't actually
thought about however to achieve this
you could generate
uh yeah okay you can you could probably
generate like protobuf messages and
things but it doesn't it doesn't really
deal with with the evolution of your
messages
yeah anybody else
[Music]
just use lexical capturing yeah sure
yeah yeah if we can start from scratch
yeah well unfortunately yeah we don't we
don't
we don't we don't have that luxury yep
uh it's kind of related to the sport
capturing so
in your example you said oh i i don't
want to capture an actor
uh so how do you it seems like a
universe of things that possibly could
be captured that you wouldn't
want to get captured it seems like there
can be a lot of things and the method of
sort of specifying
like oh
so you're worried about uh things that
you don't know about
that you don't want to capture leaking
in you're just unaware of at the time so
we don't do anything we just hope we
don't do anything to help that we just
hope that if
basically the goal of this is to make it
so it's possible to write
uh frameworks that people can then rely
upon
and use and then abstract over and other
things themselves
so hopefully the goal would be that like
akka for example would know about the
types that they have in their framework
that they don't want you to accidentally
capture
and then over time you can so the whole
point about composing these constraints
is if you have some library that has
some type of socket
that they know you shouldn't capture and
akka knows you shouldn't capture an
actor
and all of these things we hope that the
library author provides that information
to you
and because you can compose these
constraints that you don't have to
actually know
anything and automatically if you
compose two things
that have these constraints hidden
inside of them then you should just
benefit from that knowledge of the
of the library designers so it's more
useful to the framework
yeah and hopefully you as a user should
just automatically
not ever accidentally capture a socket
because you're not allowed to
yeah but in
um anything that either framework says
is
hairy yeah yeah maybe that's the same
set of things
for all frameworks yeah sure you just
need a binary whether this type is hairy
yeah exactly i guess that's a it's a
good point yeah like the
danger danger will robinson marker yeah
yeah good point
so any other questions because i think
i'm getting close to time
or over time or something okay cool
thank you